for folks that don't know if you don't
mind take a quick minute and give your
background on upbringing how Papa John's
got started and how it ended up turning
into a multi-billion dollar company
well I think my two really Heroes were
my dad and my grandfather my dad was a
zero entrepreneur had probably 9 or 10
11 businesses and every single one
failed so we had these bankruptcies
these Financial issues all around the
house and my grandfather who was more
conservative he had three businesses in
the law firm and they all prospered and
so how blessed was I to have the
dichotomy of being in a family that's
literally broke a year behind on the
house payments turn off electricity turn
off the gas to over here where
everything's paid for and it's safe and
it's prosperous and he gets a new
Cadillac and a new car and a new house
so it was that dichotomy that take the
risk you know you gotta if you if you're
an entrepreneur which I am by Spirit
take the risk but if you make that risk
you take that bet you better make it
good
like so so so you saw them uh on 11
businesses with your dad as well as your
grandpa at what point did you say like
my dad built 11 constantly struggling
didn't happen you know maybe I don't
want to start a business maybe I should
just go be a safer job maybe I should go
do a completely so maybe I'm going to be
a salesperson what made you say even
though you saw the struggles with your
dad I'm still going to start a business
I didn't know
um I had a grass cutting business when I
was eight nine years old I had a painted
gutters when I was 11 or 12 a little
pain company that my grandfather and I
started
um worked through high school work
through college uh had Central solar
help with my dad various companies but
really didn't know I was an entrepreneur
and I got back from graduating college
at Ball State and I couldn't find a job
and my father had a bar that was
bankrupt 57 beer joint mixed Lounge
rough bikers fights every night
everybody's drunk legit legit you're
gonna get a fight everybody this is is
in Indiana you know where you grew up
Indiana 1983 he's going bankrupt he's 64
000 in debt selling 50 Cent beers want
to know if I'd come in and help him and
we're not 10 days into this thing
and I said dad I don't think uh he
thought he was ten thousand dollars in
debt I don't think you're 10 Grandad I
think you're 20 25 that end up being 64.
and he said well
um and you were 16 at this time I'm
83 I'm 21.
um and I said no dad I think I can do
this and he said there's no way just he
was an attorney he was prosecutor
youngest City judge please just help my
reputation do what you can do and just
let the thing wonder and I said no dad I
think I can really do this I can fix
this now that was 10 days in it just was
like
um I made good grades in school
pretty good athlete but I worked harder
than other kids I mean I always had to
do things a little this running the
business was like falling out of this
chair it was the most natural make the
beer cold have good people serving it
smile clean the place up make sure the
mcburger is hot and have a pool
tournament on Sunday at Euchre
tournament on Tuesday Little Kings on
Thursday but it was the most intuitive
things and we're 64 000 in bankruptcy
Labor Day weekend of 83 I sell the car
for 2 800 in October of 83.
we paid off thirty two thousand dollars
by January 1st of Eighty Four in Clark
County State Bank loaned me the other 32
Grand in less than four months we went
from bankruptcy to solve it wow yeah it
was just a it was just it was my gift I
gave you confidence that gave you a
little bit of confidence where maybe I
can operate a business I was confident
okay got it so that's nice so your
struggling wasn't being confident
um it was when I went in okay it was
before I went in but after I went in it
was like okay I can run a business and
your dad just couldn't figure it out but
you could at 21. and he was a grown man
judge lawyer and he just couldn't
operate a business but you came in at 21
Hotshot and figured it out how did that
work
yeah Dad was just he was happy-go-lucky
he loved the racetrack he believed in
absentee ownership he thought the thing
would run itself whereas Papaw was save
every nickel you know a penny saved as a
penny earned you have to be there you
have to tend to the shop but
entrepreneurship runs on all four sides
of the grandparents all four so
entrepreneurship was in the blood I just
didn't know it that was your original
question when did you did you know it I
didn't until I got thrown in the the
Lion's Den in a pork chop suit and
survived I love it so you pay it you
help now you're solvent at what point do
you leave and say I'm gonna go do it on
my own
we're December January 83 84. and
um my dad had a joke
um John gets him drunk at night and I
get him divorced in the morning because
he was attorney I hated we were good
great business model
yeah
I hated the bar business I hated the
drinking the smoking the fights
um you're really doing something that's
negative impact on human beings which is
part of my soul that I just totally
disagree with
and I had this idea for a pizza place
when I was up in Muncie Indiana because
I'd made pizzas at Rocky's subhub and
also made pizzas under Chris camerasini
the Greek at greets Pizzeria so I had
all the recipes and the design of the
place and the logo and um I think it was
March February March I go I know what
I'm gonna do I'm gonna bust that broom
closet down that wall and I'm gonna put
me some news to restaurant equipment in
there and I'm gonna take that box with
the recipes and the logo and we're going
to do five dollar pizzas out the back
and 50 Cent beers out the front with a
50 Cent game of pool that was our
business model
for five bucks pizza 50 Cent beer and 50
Cent game of pool 50 Cent game of pool
and and we got we got the pool tables up
to a thousand a week I used to go in the
bank where they had a machine a thousand
dollars uh that's two thousand games in
quarters and quarters in each hand the
girl the girl behind the counter the
banks teller was kind of cute and I'd
walk again
I would pay me in quarters we were doing
anything and then we're doing three
grand a week in pizza sales in the broom
closet and we're doing seven thousand
weeks on 50 Cent beers we're knocking
down 124 000 a year selling five dollar
pizza and 50 Cent game of pool and 50
Cent beers in 1984. wow so so at this
point have you made pizza before is this
is not done that's all I've done I made
pizzas when I was because we were
talking outside is
um I was a dishwasher Rockies uh 235 an
hour uh 1977 78. that was minimum wage
um and I hated washing dishes and right
across from my wash dishes where Joe
fondrice made pizzas and the fondrice
brothers Joe John and Frank ran Rocky
subpop and I always dreamed you know
getting uh promoted from washing dishes
to making pizza and they got it right up
in the Saturday scene in Louisville uh
Joe fondrice went to the front of the
house to host us and John Snyder Papa
John got promoted promotion dishes to
make him pizza and I fell in love with
it I loved everything about it so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]